[Music]
it was my privilege 26 years ago to
award you your bachelor's degree and 25
years ago your master's degree
it was soon recognised that your first
straight performance as a teacher was
matched by first-rate talent as an
administrator and you were quickly
co-opted from one administrative job
after another in fact you hardly had the
opportunity to arm the chair in one post
before you were drafted for no
it's very nice to have so many people
from so many institutions and so many
old friends who have come back today to
participate in this celebration I got to
know Paul Gray when I was beginning
graduate school but we really became
close when I became his Provost I first
met him through his deep involvement in
undergraduate education at MIT he was a
great friend a great colleague but also
a very great teacher for me
I got involved as an athlete as a
swimmer as a rower as a sailor and I
would often see him and I would invite
him to our competitions and he would
come and I remember he and Priscilla
coming into swimming meet and just
sitting down and staying for the whole
time he was a quietly very brave
tenacious man loving and kind and gentle
and very focused and always very engaged
he loved being around experts and taking
advice from experts and learning from
experts and sharing with experts he was
the father who took us hiking biking
swimming sailing skating he's the one
who ran behind us when we were learning
to ride our bikes until we could do it
on our own
there were no training wheels you just
figured it out
[Music]
Paul began his MIT life as a freshman
Paul came to imagine 1950 so that's
almost 70 years has just simply
remarkable I cannot think of anybody
else who gave so much of his life is
sure so much of his life was visited
he's a very down-to-earth individual
very straightforward man but very caring
he did so much for him I teared he did
it he did it morning noon at night you
so devoted to this place and to the
students in such a genuine way he was
never in it for himself he was always in
it for MIT
some years ago in a commencement in the
rain a father was heard to say after the
soaking I've taken for the last four
years who minds a little rain
but I have to say this is something else
in the competitive sport of diving the
various dives are ranked according to
the degree of difficulty when the
performances of different divers are
equal the diver who chooses to dive with
the highest degree of difficulty wins
now by that measure alone you here today
or Winterson you have chosen and
successfully negotiated a collegiate
education having what may be the
nation's highest degree of difficulty
[Applause]
and we always called it this special
place I think for him it really was a
special place and a kind of home unlike
he'd ever had before because it
satisfied him intellectually and it
satisfied him I think emotionally and
when he was able to connect his own
family to it then I think that that was
sort of a full-circle
em idea is best known for the scientists
and engineers who had studied there he
was at MIT at a time when engineering
changed completely from largely
empirical practice of making things and
making them work to a situation where
science and understanding fundamentals
affected the design and the
implementation of so many systems this
very gentle quiet fierce man I know had
to do battle to get Whitehead Institute
established before terribly suspicious
and you know frankly he wasn't sure what
it would be nobody was it was an
experiment and he took the risk
MIT in the biomedical Enterprise in
Kendall Square is unrivaled anywhere in
the world and so I do credit Paul with
setting us out in that direction so the
Whitehead we now have the broad and the
Reagan the Koch Institute any number of
expressions of the power of biology to
transform our world when I came to MIT
which was in 1965 I think maybe two or
three percent of the students were women
fewer than that on the faculty it was
very much a male institution he was
tremendously committed to diversity
increasing the representation in the
faculty and in a student body of women
and of minorities the number of entering
african-american students at MIT went
from about three to five per year to 57
to this day I mean we're just very proud
of that momentum Apple brought to the
table on this issue MIT has a
responsibility to itself and to the
nation to be open and indeed to reach
out to the most talented and promising
people regardless of race or sex none of
us created all the bias around us but we
certainly inherit it and what I love
about president gray is that he stepped
right into that and as soon as he saw it
and understood it he decided to actually
do something about it
during his inauguration what he wanted
as the walking in music was Aaron
Copland's fanfare for the common man and
that was him you know
[Music]
he always was in touch with his very
modest beginnings in a blue-collar
family where you know the economy was a
challenge
one of his fraternity brothers while he
was at MIT as a sophomore was dating a
woman at Wheaton College where my mother
was a freshman they introduced my
parents on what turned out to be a
rather successful blind date it was very
cold and they're walking across the
bridge and my mother doesn't have any
gloves and the my father said I've got a
pair of gloves why don't we do this I'll
wear the left one
you wear the right one and we'll hold
hands to keep the middle ones warm and
they walked across the bridge and they
walked off into the future that was the
first day of their relationship I
thought well that's that's pretty good
for a nerd from New Jersey a very clever
use of a pair of gloves to win the
girl's heart
[Music]
it was the big blizzard of 78 and no
cars were allowed on the road you know
for a week but and whitey was not going
to shut down so we started this bus line
and one of my favorite pictures of Paul
Gray is with his big wolf skin or beaver
skin hat you know with like a Russian
hat out in the parking lot at MIT where
the buses came in directing traffic I
mean he was very much hands-on he looks
incredibly happy actually in the picture
he was just doing what he could do I
think and having fun doing it I think he
had a lot of joy in what he did
he was a real proponent of the
undergraduate research opportunities
program Europe it was dramatically
successful and found a way for
undergraduates to interact with the
faculty in their research project this
would be a way in which students could
for the first time perhaps in her years
at MIT come to terms with an unsolved
real problem something where they could
make a genuine contribution that became
an integral part of how MIT educate
students so it was a huge thing for us
when he finished up all the
administrative and leadership roles that
he had MIT he went back to the classroom
he loved being in the classroom you
turned the crank on a 3 by 3 matrix and
solve for the node voltages he sub B he
sub C and E sub D he was an absolutely
excellent teacher clarity complete
concerned with the students
understanding very much enjoyed being in
their company professor gray was my
academic adviser when I was an undergrad
here at MIT and I remember he was a
really warm very friendly giving advisor
at first maybe you would think it might
be a little intimidating having your
advisors would be the ex-president of
MIT but that turned out not to be the
case at all professor gray was extremely
down-to-earth he really understood
technological education and what of a
technological research university is
really about and how precious it is
[Music]
one of the many involvements that the
greys had with students what are these
senior dinners we invited the whole
class to dinner 60 or 70 at a time all
of us at MIT we just celebrate the
opportunities to be with those students
they are so special
every semester on registration day we
would meet with him and then that
evening all of us all of his advisers
would go out to dinner with him always
at the Royal East you can imagine there
was sort of a a big table usually in the
back of the restaurant all filled with
I'd say maybe about ten or so advisees
yours is the obligation to help heal
with society where healing is required
to help strengthen the nation's we're
strengthening is required and to help
bring harmony among the nations of this
world wherever discord obtains if you
have ever seen Paul's official
presidential portrait it is a portrait
of Paul in Priscilla he was the first
person to have his spouse in the picture
right and I think that for him that was
a measure of his devotion for her his
appreciation for all the things that my
mother may have sacrificed in order to
help him have the roles and the
opportunities that he had and all the
ways in which she supported him I think
that that was his way of saying you know
I wouldn't have been able to do this
without Priscilla was extraordinary to
watch them together how they work
together how they supported each other
they both had a twinkle in their eye
they were kind of pinging at you
just to know that there was someone sort
of watching over us making sure that
things generally are probably gonna be
okay for us so I really appreciated that
very much he is a man of exceptional
integrity the humanists of the van and
of Priscilla was so essential to the
kind of leadership he provided at MIT he
cared about people
a person with tremendous integrity a
person with tremendous wisdom thoughtful
calm an extraordinarily forceful person
but also with a surprisingly gentle
personality he's good at listening he
was good at negotiating and meeting
people partway and he was good at
imagining what might be possible if this
shifted our that changed or we could
move forward together in this direction
as you undertake this next stage in your
lives I wish for you a life that is rich
in opportunities to stretch your talents
your interests your imagination and your
vision of this small planet as a
beautiful oasis generating peace and as
you depart from this special place I
wish you Godspeed
[Music]
you